I mean you've gone through it yourself
like you go through doctors you go
through Specialists people tell you this
is the only option or they try things it
doesn't work and they're essentially
left to figure it out on their own
unfortunately chronic pain is also one
of them because a lot of patients pain
meds eventually stop working and they're
left to figure out okay what do I do now
I can't just live like this for the rest
of my life chronic pain is obviously a
big thing but even fibromyalgia like
chronic fatigue syndrome uh obviously
toxic mold uh and then there's there's
more complicated conditions like
neurodegerative conditions that dealing
with too because let's be honest like if
you have a neurodegenerative condition
they're kind of just waiting for you to
just get
worse a lot of people are not okay with
that model anymore they want to do
something about it so that's where
regenerative medicine obviously comes
in and then longevity instead of just
kind of telling people hey you can
exercise you should do this as your V2
Max and so on we're actually giving them
tools to enhance their body so can you
tell me how exactly it works cuz gene
therapy sounds a little bit scary yeah
exactly
so Dr Khan welcome to my podcast yeah
thanks for having me in person this time
I know this is fun thanks for coming out
here yeah last time I was in Dubai we
did it virtually yeah this is better
this is better much better um so I asked
people from my audience if they had
questions for you so I have a bunch of
those and then I have some of mine in
here too just to keep things flowing uh
but first
question highest to death ratio on
Halo yeah
so I guess they watch your dad's daily
wire and my autobiography so for people
who don't know I was uh I was a champion
a world champion in uh the Halo 1
original Halo 1 series on Xbox back then
though to be fair there was a lot less
competition uh that's hilarious I I I
think I I mean I I don't I don't know
how to answer that but I think I think
in general my ratio was probably oo like
5 to one on average I don't know what
that means it basically means like it's
it's called a killing spree this is they
would know what that means but
essentially for every five people you
kill you die once ah okay wow but you
decided to trans transition into regen
medicine as cool as I was I was like I
need to uh actually it was it wasn't
just the nerdiness it was more just I I
actually wanted to do something
meaningful uh so that's what got me into
medicine it was it was it's when you're
when you're 18 I mean you're just kind
of like naive and you're like how do I
help people the most and obviously you
think being a doctor is the best way uh
which is awesome but now the reality is
being a doctor is just small piece of
the puzzle because I think as you and me
have talked about a lot of this is
scaling the technology and building
businesses to help more people yeah so
since last year since you've been on
you've been making the rounds for
podcast I've seen you with a whole bunch
of like celebrity type people and so
what are what are people asking for that
you
do yeah it's it's a whole spectrum
because there's I would say two main
categories let's say one is like orphan
diseases and then the other is just like
longevity and anti-aging so orphan
diseases what that means is essentially
conditions that are not being addressed
by our medical system so I mean you've
gone through it yourself like you you go
through doctors you go through
Specialists people tell you this is the
only option it may or they try things it
doesn't work and they're essentially
left to figure it out on their own and
that's orphan disease there's so many of
them uh unfortunately chronic pain is
also one of them because a lot of
patients pain meds eventually stop
working and they're left to figure out
okay what do I do now I can't just live
like this for the rest of my life so a
lot of them chronic pain is obviously a
big thing but even fibromyalgia like
chronic fatigue syndrome uh obviously
toxic mold uh and then there's there's
more complicated conditions like
neurodegerative conditions that were
dealing with too because let's be honest
like if you have a neurodegenerative
condition they're kind of just waiting
for you to just get worse and the
medication just for symptom management
uh a lot of people are not okay with
that model anymore they want to do
something about it so that's where
regenerative medicine obviously comes in
uh and then longevity is obviously
pretty self-explanatory but instead of
just kind of telling people hey you can
exercise you should do this as your V2
Max and so on we're actually giving them
tools to enhance their body so they can
do more of that for a longer period of
time and obviously that's like the
premier one is obviously the fall and
gene therapy which I'm sure we'll get
into hey guys so last year before I
discovered mold in my house causing all
my issues I had my hormones tested on
the off chance I was having a hormone
issue which I was my hormones were
flattened like all of them they
recovered somewhat after moving out of
that house given I got pregnant a month
after I moved out after not getting
pregnant for a few years um but I wanted
to talk to you about the company I used
to test my hormones mer health they're
my go-to tella Health company for labs
hormones peptides Physicians that don't
suck they gave me an in-depth look at my
hormones compared to what you'd get at a
regular doctor's office you can sign up
and choose what you want to get tested
or choose some of their panels and they
give you your results broken down and
recommendations for supplements peptides
or treatments that work they're super
easy to work with very straightforward
you get all your information I'm a huge
proponent of monitoring blood work I
think everyone should do it my husband's
now working with them my dad my brother
and me they do work other than hormone
optimization like cognitive enhancement
hair loss prevention body recomposition
the complete package includes the same
elaborate panel I got myself and
actually just redid so we'll see what it
shows now that I'm not living in mold
and with those test results the meric
health clinical team suggests ways to
optimize hormones to get the exact same
panel and medical oversight I got click
the link in the video description or go
to meric health.com Michaela and use
codee MP to save 10% at checkout highly
recommended pinned in the description I
hope you guys are enjoying this episode
yeah let's get let's actually start off
with that one so you're going to give
that to me my husband's already taken it
and from what I've seen he's definitely
more muscular he says he can lift like
more weight for longer periods of time
and I was kind of worried about it
because I'm always worried about any
type of intervention
um and fall stattin I didn't understand
very well so can you tell me how exactly
it works because gene therapy sounds a
little bit scary yeah exactly so instead
of thinking this like a gene therapy
because that word has a lot of
connotations behind it just think of it
as a delivery system to increase your
follow stattin levels back to when you
were younger and fall Statin is a
naturally occurring peptide in your body
and as you get older the levels decrease
just like many p epes in your body do so
we're just restoring something back to a
normal level and why follow Statin yeah
there's there's many reasons number one
is very safe so that was probably the
biggest reason why our team chose to
make that the first
Target even if you overdose on fallatin
it's not going to do anything it's it's
meaning it's all going to just saturate
The receptors and there's no real side
effects from that the worst case
scenario is it doesn't work uh because
there it's been around for over 20 years
it's not a new molecule uh it's been
discovered for a long time but the the
kind of the Breakthrough was to get it
to stay in your system because follow
Statin as a peptide has a half life of
90 minutes oh okay so the peptides that
you can like if you Google follow Statin
bu off like anywhere but you'd have to
inject yourself like 10 times a day and
wake up in the middle of the night for
you to keep your level steady and that's
obviously not practical so that's why no
one really prescribes fall STA and and
no one really uses the online ones
because the half lifee is just way too
short so this is just a delivery
mechanism to keep your level steady for
18 to 24 months with one injection wow
and the the reason it's the gene therapy
is because the way we're transmitting
the fallatin into your body is using
what's called a plasmid Vector so it's a
it's technically a foreign DNA but none
of your genome or your Gene is actually
being edited so it's very different from
like crisper crisper is like the gene
editing technology where you actually ch
people's genomes or you edit something
to correct it and that's obviously much
more risky because you can have offsite
targets and you're playing with people's
genetics and that's why it took crisper
like 12 or 13 years to finally get one
product on the market and even then
there are you know some serious risks
with it so whereas what we have is
basically just we inject it into your
arm and the local tissue there is now
transformed or genetically modified but
your whole body is not genetically
modified you know what I mean like it's
essentially just a local tissue there
now is secreting the F Statin and
bringing your levels back up to a more
optimal range basically okay so like
correct me if this is wrong but for a
plasmid Vector does that mean it this
little tiny like blob makes it way into
your mitochondria is that where it goes
yeah well nucleus eventually yeah okay
cool exactly that's what it does exactly
but it doesn't edit your genes no and it
just makes it way in there because it's
plas and the plasmid Vector the beauty
of it is derived from eoli but there no
live bacteria so there's no risk of like
getting like infection or something like
from viruses viral vectors and then the
other thing is it's non-immunogenic so
you don't have to be on amuno
suppressants so because there are viral
Gene therapies out there that have even
follow sta in viral gene therapy but
there's risk with that and I think and
and the other thing is it's not
reversible if you take a viral gene
therapy you can't reverse it because
it's a virus what what's an example of
that so like it's called adino
Associated viral vector like aav that's
like the most common V Vector for
viruses and there there's actually why
why would somebody take that because
they don't think there's any other
option out there but okay but the
reality is now with the plasma plasmid
it's it's such a better technology
because it's non-immunogenic it's
reversible because it's of ecoli origin
you can just take a tetracycline and
it's a it's a kill switch so let's just
say for whatever reason you want it out
of your body you just take this
antibiotic and it's out so it has a
safety mechanism built into it whereas
viruses there no safety mechanism so if
you want it out you can't get it out uh
and it's not it's not repeatable either
eventually it'll stop working and that's
it whereas this one can be repeated as
many times as you want like every 18 to
24 months when it wears off so it has
those safety features that really
separated from either vectors out there
not to mention for people who haven't
heard of vectors like the vector that
was probably the most common talked
about in the last couple years was the
lipid nanoparticle Vector which was what
was used for Co
yeah and the problem with the lipid
nanoparticle Vector was that it can also
have offsite targets and it's
immunogenic so it can stimulate your
immune system aside from just the MRNA
signal that they're trying to use to
kind of vaccinate your body there can be
off-site effects and that's why I think
we maybe didn't fully understand that
when it came out uh but now we're
obviously seeing a lot more people have
adverse reactions and I've seen that
clinically too obviously like and it it
if if i' I've literally had patients who
never had any issues and then they got
the vaccine and it just stimulated their
immune system and now they have an
autoimmune condition and they're dealing
with chronic issues or chronic and we're
able to treat them with what we do but
the fact is they need treatment it's not
like it's just going to go away on its
own could they have used this plasmid
Vector for the covid vaccine or yeah I
mean and theoretically you could uh and
that's but I don't they want Yeah well
yeah fair enough would that have po
potentially solve some of these like
major side effects of people because I
think about why is the vaccine causing
problems in people I think it's because
of the
immunogenicity because of that
stimulating the immune system and that
your immune system is so important for
regulating so many different things
that's why you get these weird kind of
things they're like why are people
getting these weird reactions to it when
we don't see that with other vaccines
you know what I
mean and uh I think the other thing
obviously is the purification process
like how do you actually purify it so
that where What's called the DNA
fragments from how you synthesize it and
create it are all filtered out and
there's been studies now published
showing that the DNA fragment in the
MRNA vaccine was higher than the
allotted amount recommended by World
Health Organization ah
so so the purification you would think
for something that's been given to
billions of people would go through a
better rigorous process to make sure
there's no DNA fragment so I think
there's just probably things that
weren't done optimally uh I don't know
you know if I don't think we'll ever
know if this was on purpose or if this
was by you know just accident but it is
what it is well even I mean they could
have easily just been rushed
through cuz it was rushed through yeah
exactly and maybe they didn't have the
checks and balances that they should
have yeah oh that's so unfortunate so
are you treating people for vaccine
injury yes it's successfully yeah yeah
it's there's different protocols
depending on what symptoms they have but
generally there's like very common
patterns which is essentially like
immune dysfunction which can present as
chronic fatigue or sometimes even like
full-blown like rheumatoid arthitis or
autoimmune conditions develop afterwards
I've seen that as well and so it's
almost like we have to reboot their
immune system and so that's takes
peptides something called bioregulators
which help promote dius gland function
and and then uh the intravenous stem
cells because the intravenous stem cells
more than anything what they do cuz a
lot of people think when they think stem
cells they like oh you're reg growing or
repairing tissue but first generation
stem cells are more for reprogramming
your immune system it's called
immunomodulation so basically taking
your body from like a pro-inflammatory
state to an anti-inflammatory state so
it's kind of Shifting and a lot of times
after vaccine injuries that's what's
happening it's like they're in this
chronically inflamed state so like cyto
kind storms EX but but it's like chronic
low grade inflammation and where where
is that coming from it's coming from
obviously your immune system which is
based mainly in your gut and then OB
there there's a thymus gland too those
are like the two main components of how
your immune system is regulated so if we
can restore function to those using
peptides and bio regulators and stem
cells then we often get we get pretty
great results and then the we have the
fmt which we were we're producing our
own now so that should that's just in
the process of being ready that's cool
yeah
that's cool so are any of these uh well
actually let's start with this what's a
bioregulator like what's an example of
one of those yeah so a
bioregulator I think most people have
heard of peptides but ins insulin is a
peptide that was made like 100 years ago
it's a signal to your body to say hey
lower blood sugar and move mobilize it
outside of the blood into the cells and
so there's different peptides now that
can help with energy weight loss like
obviously there o zic which became
really popular but by Regulators are a
similar type of signal except they're
signal to an organ so instead of being
for like a specific function it's a
specific organ so what they do is they
basically upregulate the function of an
organ so for example there's
bioregulators for the pancreas there's
bioregulators for muscle there's
bioregulators for your skin there's
bioregulators for your thymus gland and
what the bioregulator is doing it's
upregulating or promoting the function
of that organ because you may have some
chronic low-grade dysfunction of of that
organ meaning it's not doing its job as
well as it should and can and you can
test that so you can find out which
organs are working well EXA yeah and
then and you can test it and then you
can also obviously based off clinical
history and symptoms and examination and
you do your assessment and you say okay
like your thymus gland is obviously an
issue because you have this autoimmune
condition and based off the test that
we've done uh and then you can kind of
prescribe that as part of the protocol
wow okay and is this an injection or an
infusion they're actually pills uh so
they're pretty simple to take
have been around in in Russia for like
20 30 years I think
Russians so they've been around quite a
while just again unfortunately because
they're not really patentable they're
not have the same uh presence as in the
in the western world oh that's a nice
way of putting it that was a very polite
way of putting it so are you able
to you're are you able to offer any of
these in the US or is it just uh
unfortunately FDA is going backwards I'm
you've heard about what they've did with
peptides recently yeah yeah that's
terrible yeah so you can explain
actually for anyone who doesn't know
yeah I mean unfortunately the FDA
decided that the compounding pharmacies
which are legitimately making peptides
with high standards GMT GMP like
certified fa like you know factories and
making these peptides uh are no longer
allowed to so because they're saying
that there's they need to be regulated
of course that's what and and then
they're saying that they can be harmful
uh so they've essentially banned
peptides from Clinical use for doctors
to prescribe them all of them like what
about OIC for examp unless you're
patented and by drug company so so you
can't prescribe tritide which is the
generic version of mjo which is a second
generation OIC it's it's basically like
OIC except it also improves insulin
sensitivity so that one's like let's say
the new kit on the Block so to
speak but the generic form of it is
called tritide which you could get from
almost any peptide manufacturing or
compounding pharmacy and it would
probably be a tenth of the price but
because it's not a patented molecule
that can be prescribed uh like on scale
then they don't they don't allow you to
give it to patients like legally so you
have to prescribe Muro the brand name
and you have to and patients if their
insurance covers it they'll cover it but
otherwise they have to pay for it and
and the funny thing is that Muro is
basically the same molecule except they
add like you know some like component to
it that does that's inert doesn't add
any value to it but then it allows them
to patent the molecule because it's
different from the generic version yeah
that's crazy so is it still illegal to
like buy these things online from these
Shifty places unfortunately that's what
happens right I think you're basically
just getting more people who are going
to just be like okay well my doctor is
not allowed to prescribe it anymore so I
guess I'll just order it online and see
what happens uh and that's yeah that's
problematic obviously for any reason
because you don't know the quality most
of the peptide manufacturers are
Manufacturing in China and then they
just say made in us and like with the
online ones so you have to be careful
where you go oh that's very
unfortunate okay let's go to another
question if you guys are into biohacking
which you probably are if you're
watching this episode yet you still
consume the occasional beverage consider
checking out my hangover supplement
Afterparty available at Fuller
health.com code
mp15 for 15% off 30-day money back
guarantee it reduces the impact of
alcohol on your brain and body by
helping you detox Faster by breaking
down acetal ahid the toxic byproduct of
alcohol that poisons you I don't know
why anyone wouldn't use it if they drink
sometimes Fuller health.com Linked In
the description I hope you're enjoying
this episode actually let's let's cover
this I don't think this was a question
this is my question you were talking
before we got started about Vegas nerve
treatments so I have the this like step
uncle who's always talking about like
random things that and I'm not sure if
they exist or not and he was always
talking about like a vagal nerve and how
important this is and I was like okay
whatever but like what what is this
Vagas nerve what is it and then what are
treatments and why are they necessary
for some people your your step uncle had
good intuition because the Vegas nerve
is kind of like the Gateway into your
nervous system so what that means is
it's it's one of the well it is the
biggest ner in your body and where is it
it it's around well start like I mean
kind of like around here it's where we
inject but it runs through your whole
diaphragm and inates that as well uh and
it communicates with your spleen it
communicates with uh even your brain so
the biggest thing for people to
understand is it's basically your
autonomic nervous system which is kind
of it's it's
normally in charge of obviously there's
a motor component which is like in you
know from the spinal cord and everything
but your nervous system can also be
what's called sympathetic overdrive like
where essentially you're in this fight
or flight mode and a lot of people with
PTSD or trauma they're in this
hyperaroused state even when they don't
want to be and people with anxiety
people with irritability and honestly a
lot of people just because of stress and
because of the modern society uh and the
other thing too is like it can be
sometimes a situational right like it
could be even performance-based anxiety
where you don't want your nervous system
to get all anxious and but you can't but
certain things are associated with it
and so almost like automatic and so you
can't control that so it becomes really
obviously people do like meditation
there's veal stve there's to your
question like there's vagal nerve
stimulators which go on the outside to
try to stimulate the vagus nerve why
because the vagus nerve goes to your
parasympathetic nervous system which is
like the relax or digest system
basically helps to calm you down so
sympathetic is fight and then
parasympathetic is relax and so we're
what we're doing is we're trying to put
this back into balance because it
becomes disregulated so so this is on
this is on too much and this is not
going on enough so it's like you can't
relax properly and a lot of this can be
because of adrenal disregulation as well
where your cortisol is all messed up and
that can be a contributing factor but
they're kind of intertwined because a
lot of times people get their cortisol
regulated but their nervous system is
still like the problem a problem uh so
it's not just hormones it's the nervous
system too which is a low hanging fruit
and so what we do is we basically just
inject exosomes and peptides into the
Vegas nerve and then there's something
called a stellic ganglion which feeds
into the sympathetic nervous system and
we we use anesthetic so it's called a
block but we also inject peptides so it
actually modulates wow and changes the
signaling because EST stellia gangan
block has been around for like yeah ever
forever like it's called sgb block and
it's covered by most insurance companies
now and a lot of veterans get it but it
only lasts like three months uh and then
people have to repeat it so what we do
with our approach like many of our
patients been over a year and they
haven't needed it again and and i' I've
helped young girls with anxiety from
like 1-year-olds but I've helped like
men in their 60s who were like Special
Forces operatives so it's it's a huge
gamut of people who can benefit from it
I've also done it for like I had a pro
golfer he wrote us a reviews so I can
talk about it so online his name is Matt
wolf and he's uh he's he has like a I
think he has one of the fastest golf
swings in the world but he had a lot of
performance anxiety and it was only when
he was playing away not at home in
Florida and so was it was obviously to
do with just like being away from home
and stuff like that but but the Vegas
nerve injection helped him a ton just to
calm his nervous system down and be more
focused when he's I want this yeah it's
pretty yeah it's pretty cool oh wow
that's interesting okay have you heard
of uh I mean you've obviously heard of
like brain retraining like I've seen
this in a lot of people who have chronic
illness where they try dieting and it
helps a bit and they try detoxing and it
helps a bit and they can't calm their
nervous system down ex this allows for
he and that's exactly what this is it's
basically a loow hanging intervention
that's calming your nervous system down
that allow other interven ions to work
better because your body can if your
nervous system's all jacked up it's so
hard to heal and the nervous system and
immune system communicate with one
another so there can be chronic
inflammation in your nervous system as
well which can contribute to so many
other pathologies right like
neuroinflammation chronic pain
neuropathic pain stuff like that so like
I had uh Chris Bell he he had he had
like this really bad knee pain forever
and we obviously inject his stem cells
whatever but the first thing we did was
the Vegas nerve injection and he said
the next day his pain was gone oh my go
I know and he he made a video about it
but we were just like I was kind of like
what what do you mean your Pain's gone
so obviously there's like we don't fully
understand it yet that's why there has
to be a lot more research done I think
in this area but there's obviously this
communication between your nervous
system and your immune system that's
going on and and I think that's a that's
why I think it's such a good
intervention because it can help so many
people did you talk to Dad about this
one we talked about the research we're
going to do which is essentially using
it for neuros psychiatric like PTSD
depression yeah and then doing we're
probably G to do a phase one because
obviously this is all like I mean I have
hundreds of now we have anecdotes but we
need to probably do a clinical trial at
some point to show that this is
Meaningful and like track more data uh
but we want to do a trial like combining
this with like stoc cybin assisted
therapy or something like that uh to
show like long long-term results of how
the Vegas nerve in combination with
therapy can yield like really powerful
results I want to try this I feel like
part of my immune system overdrive I
don't know it might just be mold it
might just be like long-term but mold
hijacks your cells in a sense right so
they hijack them and they prevent them
from functioning properly it's called
cell suppression
Theory heard of it yeah I have heard of
that I don't I mean I don't like that
the idea of that at all I know but
that's what mold is mold is a smart you
know uh pathogen so it it it literally
can hijack and suppress your cell
functions hence the name self supression
Theory and then that can cause all sorts
of different dysfunctional cellular
Hallmarks H interesting okay I'm
probably going to hit you up for the
Vegas nerve treatment that sounds worth
a shot sounds a lot easier than this
brain retraining like I a lazy way well
we we'll combine it with like brain tap
have you heard of brain tap yeah but
describe that it's it's like the headset
piece that you wear and has guided
different types of guided therapy
programs so a lot of people will use
that to rewire their their brain and
rewire their kind of uh mental state
does that take a long time it does and
that's the thing it takes it can take
months and months and this is just like
a shortcut I think to kind of make those
things easier but like to show you like
how dramatic this can be I had a girl
just like two weeks ago she's like 23 24
and she was she was actually admitted to
a psychiatric hospital just before she
came to see me because she was so like
like hyper anxious and like to a point
where she was becoming suicidal a and uh
and she's been like this for two years
and she's tried everything and then
after the procedure she started crying
because she said she felt like relief
for the first time in two years and
relaxed and relaxed like like 10 minutes
after I was just like this is
crazy wow okay okay I'm G to come and do
that yeah I've done it on myself so I
can tell you and I'm not an anxious
person but yeah I'm just I mean for me
it was more for just like I have so much
stress in my life and uh just it making
me more calm and relax and is there a
downside though what happens if you do
this on someone who's already chill yeah
I mean I'm pretty chill it's just you
become lethargic no it's no that's the
thing it's modulating right and that's
how peptides and exosomes work in
general they modulate they don't they're
not going to doce anything if there's
nothing needed to be done so it's not
going to make you like a sloth or
something okay I I need a lot to make me
alth although you know uh my wife just
had it done too and she um the reason
she's postpartum like yourself and she
uh I think I think postpartum it can be
super helpful because postpartum
depression is a real problem and a lot
of times that's based in anxiety and
that's based in these thought patterns
and doing a nervous doing a nervous
system reset postpartum makes a lot of
sense to me I think this would be a
great thing because right now postpartum
they have the these Pharmaceuticals that
really don't do much and they push them
because obviously that's all they have
to push
right cool okay well I'm going to do
that that sounds like a great idea and I
don't want to do the brain retraining I
feel like it takes too long I keep
looking at it being like my nervous
system is definitely a little stressed
out and maybe that's contributing to
some of these symptoms which which
doesn't mean that they're like in my
head I'm getting like flaring up from
like allergens and all these things but
like why am I allergic to the world
exactly we have to build resiliency in
your body and part of that start the big
part of that's the nervous system and
obviously the fall Statin and then we
we'll get you the fmt as well because I
think transplanting new bacteria is into
your gut makes a lot of sense I'm sure
yeah oh yeah for sure I did that though
a bu came out right yeah I did that at T
Mount and then they can send samples and
I did them at home and it just I think I
was just too Dam damag I also think my
gut was too permeable for it to make
sense right and that's where it's
reducing inflammation with the falat and
IV may be a first good first step to
repair the lining and then do fmt after
cool okay okay great um oh okay so
people asked you about beauty treatments
and I know that you're you're delving
into that so what do you guys offer I'll
I'll make a disclaimer which is I my
passion is not Beauty but it was a
necessary let's call it evil because uh
so people ask about it and so I took it
upon myself to learn and I learned from
two plastic surgeons one in Switzerland
and one in Japan and both of these
people have been doing uh stem cells for
cosmetic purposes for 10 years so they
have tons of experience and they're
plastic surgeons and they're cosmetic
doctors and you're probably wondering
why are surgeons doing this because
they've seen great results and they
don't have to cut people open so there's
a reason why they're offering it to
their patients and and the cool thing
about so essentially your skin is aging
just like the rest of your body is aging
as time passes and of course Botox can
help in the acute setting but it's not
doing anything to slow down the aging
process and what causes your skin to age
it's it's similar processes as anything
else in your body which is there's
there's 10 maybe arguably like 12
Hallmarks of Aging now so I'm not going
to list all 12 of them but for for but
but let's let's list a few of them like
mitochondrial dysfunction syence
Associated secretary phenotype sasp this
is a long word but it basically just
means chronic inflammation uh stem cell
exhaustion where stem cells become
exhausted and they can't repair as much
oxidative stress gut to biosis so and
then just tell me utrition there's all
these other ones but essentially there
just all these Hallmarks that are
consistent in almost every chronic
disease because aging is the most
complex chronic disease and there's a
huge investment of research going into
solving aging because if we can solve
aging we can actually treat a lot of
chronic illness because aging is the
most comp complex form of it and the
Hallmarks that underly aging also
underly how your skin age is why you're
why you start getting heart disease as
you get older why you get
neurodegenerative conditions as you get
older they're all the same like
underlying similar dysfunctional
patterns so so in the skin if you if you
okay you understand that okay it's
because mitochondria aren't functioning
well it's because you get this chronic
inflammation you get all these free
radicals that build up from sun damage
and exposure so what can you do actually
Target those mechanisms so that's what
we're going after so it's not like we're
just trying to say okay make the skin
look good and come back in three months
we're trying to not only slow down signs
of aging but it may not be like you know
you because some people expect like oh
I'm going to get the facial and I'm
going to look 10 years younger like it
may take it takes time but the biggest
thing is it's going to slow down the
skin aging process which is to me which
is the big like as someone you know I'm
a big believer in prevention and
obviously like why not make your skin
healthier and slow down the signs of
aging if you can uh especially if you
know if that's something you're
interested in so what we use and this is
again I learned this in Japan is what
they we have something called There's
different type of exosomes because
there's so many places doing exosomes
now and exosomes for people who don't
know is basically the growth factors the
cyto kindes and everything that is like
the soup the stem cells grow in and they
can reduce inflammation but the problem
is you have to have specific type of
exosomes so let's call them second
generation exosomes so instead of just
being like exosomes from like
you know amniotic fluid or umbilical
cord we can actually get exosomes that
are DED from skin cells now so that's
what we're using for the face now oh
cool and that does that make a
difference yeah because it stimulates
more fibroblast and more collagen
production oh cool so we just so we just
started that this year now and it's it's
important to understand that basically
what they're doing is they take a skin
biopsy and then they use cellular
reprogramming so it's called yamanaka
factors and then they turn them back
into a baby stem cell
and then you can take those exomes and
you can inject those onto the face and
why not just take the stem cells and
inject them as opposed to the exomes you
can use both so we use both oh okay cool
the stem cells are more powerful uh so
they're in combination with exzon that's
what we do and we use like 30 million to
50 million stem cells because the dosing
is important because there's there's
lots of clinics in like Beverly Hills
and all these places being like stem
cells but they're not using true stem
cells CU it's illegal in the US to use
culture expanded stem cells where
they're grown but that's what they're
doing in Switzerland and Japan and
they've been doing it for so long that
they know that results usually last
between like it can last up to four
years but I usually tell people two to
three years which is a pretty long time
for like a you know 1 hour procedure so
it's not like you have to come back and
do it all the time wow and so is that
just like micro needling with like
topical anesthetic or something no you
actually do diabetic syringes where you
actually go into deep especially for
people who have more wrinkles and lines
or where they want to use the skin
because the skin exosomes tighten the
skin because they stimulate fibroblast
and collag production so you can inject
that directly into areas where it's more
loose to tighten it wow and then we have
uh we combin that with the Japanese uh
facial cream and facial serum that they
developed this is a really cool product
because it's called plga capsules and
it's the only technology I've seen uh
that actually penetrates into the dermis
and stays in the skin for up to 48 hours
and they Japan has done I mean I think
people who know know that Japanese and
South Koreans are probably the best when
it comes to skincare because they put so
much emphasis on that stuff and uh
they've done study theyve they took 10
years to develop this product uh but
they actually they actually have the
growth factors from their stem cell uh
medium and they they're able to put that
into a powder form and into a serum form
and it actually preserves because
there's all these like stem cell creams
out there but they're all Bs this is the
only one I've seen that actually it's
from Japan and it actually does what it
says it does wow okay I bought a stem
cell a bunch of stem cell stuff like
last year from this company that had
like they didn't have very many
ingredients in their products and I was
like I like that I understand all these
ingredients but the it's unlikely the
growth factor no medium you need a
conditioned medium and that conditioned
medium is a Japanese it's their
proprietary technology so I don't think
anyone else in the world has that as far
as I know so what I'm using is just fake
probably not doing anything I'll you I
don't think it's doing anything I'll get
you okay okay very cool okay that covers
Beauty um oh and okay before we got
started you mentioned a CTO peptide or
something oh yeah clto CTO okay okay
what is that yeah so people we explained
follow Statin yeah so clo is the same
Vector so meaning it's a plasmid and
it's also going to be can be injected
subcutaneously or into intramuscularly
and it's going to increase your clal
levels back to like an optimal range
when like let's say when you were
younger and as you get as you get older
clo also decreases so what does clo do
it helps with protect against neur
degeneration uh and it can help uh
protect against kidney disease as well
and it also Dees your body meaning it's
also anti-aging similar to follow Statin
like our the fall stattin the clinical
trial we did uh which is published now
we had on average 11 years biological
age reduction for people over 60 and H
how are you testing that a true age
diagnostic wow and they're pretty good
but like they're not perfect I think
we're we're considering switching to uh
this company called generation lab which
uses something called biological noise
it's about it's a bit more complicated
but their I think their Tech seems like
it's the best from what I've seen is
that measuring telr length or one marker
the problem is tell them your length
isn't like it's not the most accurate
representation of how your body is aging
and plus like it's it's you have to
measure different organ systems and
that's the key to it and that's what
generation lab does so that's why we're
probably going to be working with them
and their group from Harvard and they're
really bright people who've come up with
this cool technology so I'm excited to
start using their testing for for our
new work we're doing now but basically
fall stat and dhes your body let's say
on average 11 years if you're over 60 uh
and if you're if you're like our age is
still like 5 years so we still pretty
decent and but clo is similar it Dees
your body a similar amount but it all
but instead of giving you energy and
strength it can potentially make you
your memory better uh focus better and
it can help with uh maybe even increase
IQ that's one thing we're going to track
that would be nuts your dad suggested to
use braven's Progressive matrices so
we'll use that as a as a clinical in the
clinical trial which starts in March wow
yeah so is that cumulative you could
technically take fall Statin and then
this other one
exactly well you'll be good for 18 to 24
months and then you just repeat it so
the whole idea is you come you come to
our clinics you do these different
celling Gene therapies you're good for
like two years and then you just come
get them as you need them
wow has Brian Johnson does done this
cloth though what do it how do you spell
it how do you spell it k l o t h o okay
has he done that one he is eager to get
it okay yeah he did the fall I'm sure
people know he did the follow sta in
because he talked about it yeah and he
he showed his blood test he showed the
benefits of it so obviously we got a lot
of exposure from that but I think uh I
think he's a little bit also I mean just
on his I think he's a little bit extreme
obviously with his approach to longevity
but yeah but clo he's yeah he's excited
for it and so are a lot of people we're
also going to be looking at clo because
of its benefits for kidney uh we're
going to combine it with intraarterial
stem cell injections right into the
kidneys wow okay and with these stem
cell injections when like when you
inject them can you see like is there
any way to actually measure any tissue
regenerat regeneration or anything like
that yeah yeah we do ultra so for
example if you have like a tear in your
shoulder we can do an ultrasound before
and after and we can actually see the
tissue regenerate we see that all the
time with tendons and muscles uh
cartilage as well it's uh but the but
the key to let the key to all this is
second generation stem cells so second
generation stem cells is what we're just
so like we talked about second
generation exosomes so second generation
stem cells is the same technology I like
to just say yamanaka stem cells so
because it's I think it's easier to
remember than induced PL potent stem
cell yeah ipsc as it's called but
yamanaka stem cell the guy from Japan
who won the Nobel Prize for cellular
reprogramming so basically wow taking
any cell in your body and making it into
a baby stem cell that's called yamanaka
stem cell or induced plur poent stem
cell ipscs and the
ipscs I think for a lay person just
remember the this is second generation
why is a second generation because you
can ically engineer these cells to
Target specific tissue so instead of
just being like umbilical core stem
cells you can create like beta eyelid
cells for the pancreas you can create
neural progenitor cells for dementia
they've already done Parkinson's trial
this year has published ipsc dve
dopamine producing neurons oo that
sounds like fun and it actually put
patients in remission because they
transplant them and they actually
engraft and regrow new neurons and they
and they actually help patients with
Parkinson's long term so this is what
we're we're developing right now we're
working with the company and we we're
developing different ipsc cell lines so
this is going to be second generation
and that's going to be like you said
actually repairing and regenerating
tissue more so than the first generation
because they actually have more
engraftment and I think the biggest
thing for people to understand about
ipscs is that because they're like
embryonic they can the the risk is they
can grow into tumors so that's the
that's and there's a 1% chance of that
and so the the cell lines that we have
they're genetically engineered this is a
patented technology they're Gene edited
to prevent tumors or uncontrolled
proliferation and where that's the
technology we have That's Unique I I
would say compared to other companies so
our our ipss will not cause tumors
because they have this Gene edit in them
oh that's good to know yeah so is this
are you using the same technology in the
infusions yes we're switching over right
now we're still using umbilical cord uh
what are called early passage stem cells
which is means we minimize amount of
replication so we minimize it to three
passages which is important because like
a lot of stem cell clinics are doing
like 6 8 10 and it that's like it's
called replicative stress which means
you grow it too many times it makes the
cells more damaged more vulnerable and
they can actually become senescent they
don't survive and they can cause even
more harm so our cells are early passage
but we're switching over probably by the
Fall or so that we'll have the second
generation ones yeah wow wow this is so
cool what who who are the people you see
the most in the clinic out of curiosity
are they like from a specific area or is
it most
Americans yeah I mean now it's mainly
Americans I I think I mean I used to
have obviously being from Canada it was
a lot of Canadians but it's definitely
switched over in the last like year I
would say because America like I mean
obviously the population is much bigger
and there's a lot of people who are
self-educating themselves and but a lot
from Europe too and I mean even Asia now
and all over but people most common is
obviously I I'd say chronic pain that's
still like really the bread and butter
of what I do yeah yeah okay well that's
nice that you can give people relief
from that cuz that is awful it is yeah
um so Mom actually did your stem cell
therapy yeah and she did you correct me
if I'm wrong but did she get the
infusion and injections into her joints
yeah and she told me cuz I was like did
it do anything like did it work and she
said she was gardening again and she
hasn't gardened in like 10 years cuz she
had really bad arthritis in her hands
and the diet put it into remission but
like the damage had been done yeah been
done yeah and that's the thing I think
there's like a lot of like like you know
functional met doctors out there who are
just like oh you can fix everything with
diet it's not I mean there's a reason
why I have a job I think you can't
there's certain chronic diseases that
are that need something a bigger impact
to change like the physiology and then
you can obviously you can layer you can
do a layered approach where things
amplify each other like yes diet
exercise sleep stress all that stuff is
great but sometimes it's not enough to
get get rid of everything and so what we
do just kind of helps people to get over
the kind of Hump yeah that's cool I know
I got hit with like reality last year
when I was like badly exposed to it
wasn't even that it was kind of bad but
badly exposed to mold where I was
like I'm like I don't really have toxic
products I'm careful about everything I
bring into the home my diet is like one
thing and it's worked for so long and
then I got sick from mold and I was like
oh no there's this other massive factor
that been completely I hadn't been
completely ignoring because I had air
purifiers and things but I didn't
realize how much that could impact my
health when I had all these other things
in check yeah exactly and now I think
for you you've obviously you've
optimized all that stuff as much as you
can so it's like what do you do now and
that's where we come in and that's why
we're going to do the fall stattin for
you and a few other things oh okay and
I'll keep everybody posted about that um
okay let's see let's let's pick another
question from people people were
interested and like let me know how much
you can talk about this but people were
interested in different types of cancer
treatments and I know you went to Japan
and they're doing some interesting
things there yeah if I'm not wrong yeah
that's right in [__] so in Japan what I
learned was
immunotherapy so yeah so basically in in
traditional oncology I mean starting to
shift now but it's still very much
chemotherapy radiation surgery there's
starting to add something called
checkpoint Inhibitors which are
essentially a way for your body to say
to kind of stop us so what happens is
cancer becomes immuno evasive meaning
your immune system can't recognize it
and Target it and so checkpoint
Inhibitors can help to Target the cancer
so checkpoint Inhibitors are a form of
immunotherapy that are starting to be
used in the US and then there's other
form of immunotherapy instead of helping
your immune system to recognize a cancer
it actually boosts your body's own power
to fight the cancer so essentially
immunotherapy is a very broad term for
helping your immune system to deal with
cancer so that's that's like the general
definition so checkpoint Inhibitors is
one way to do it and then the other way
is actual cell therapy and there's
genetically engineered cells for example
like KT chimeric entrogen receptor which
is added onto te- cells so you take the
te- cells out of your body te- cells are
like snipers they're like you know they
go around they kill things they're
cytotoxic cells so their job is to kill
cancer and other foreign Invaders but
sometimes they become exhausted meaning
T Cell exhaustion they can't work or
cancer is so smart it puts on these
shields and your immune system can't
recognize it so what you can do is you
can you can genetically monify them with
this chimeric antigen receptor take them
out of your body and then Infuse them
back in and that can help to kill
certain type of cancers for Leukemia and
Lymphoma especially blood cancers oh wow
that sounds a lot less invasive than
chemo so in theory you could do these
other modes that are available in Japan
and you guys are doing them yeah we we
just we manufactured natural killer
cells which are part of your innate
immune system and so natural killer as
the word suggests they're natural
Killers their job is to kill foreign
pathogens cancer but again your immune
system becomes kind of hijacked when you
have cancer and it can't do what it
needs to so this can give it a boost to
help do what it needs to and same thing
with dendritic cells so dendritic cells
are what are called antigen presenting
cells so they are kind of the think of
the natural killer cells as the soldiers
and then the dendritic cells as the
general who's orchestrating telling the
soldiers where to go so that's kind of
like the general gist of how so we're
we're we're putting the infrastructure
together for your body to deal with the
cancer but the problem is we don't know
that there still needs to be more
research to figure out who are the best
candidates for immunotherapy there are
some blood tests now and genome
sequencing and there's a lot more
individualization you can do for cancer
which unfortunately is not being done
just to give you context and this is
from Dr Tom insulin who I have to give
credit to he he treats cancer here in
Scottsdale and he's he's he does whole
genome sequencing and he says the
standard of care even at the best Cancer
Centers like MD Anderson are n he 900
times less than what he's doing in terms
of like how much genome sequencing you
should be doing to figure out what's the
best type of therapy for this cancer so
there's he like that's a crazy that's
not ideal no exactly that's a crazy
amount and that's a number he used and
I'm just like wow that is but because
there's no individualization it's almost
kind of like it's just a mass approach
for everyone but it has to be like
personalized treatment for you based off
what type of cancer because there's just
so many different subtypes and depending
on the genome sequencing of the tumor
and the micro environment there's going
to be different cancer Therapies aren't
going to be more effective as a very
generic treatment protocol dendritic
cells and natural killer cells aren't
going to be harmful and they can only
help for almost any type of can because
they're basically just making your
immune system stronger and I've I've you
know Dr mie who's a Japanese doctor her
her her dad is an oncologist and he's
been doing this for over I think 15
years now in Japan and and so the
government's totally aware of this and
this is just protocol in ja exactly yeah
and so they've treated patients with
like Advanced cancer like stage four who
are still alive 10 years later today and
obviously it's one of those things like
once you see it you believe it and
there's obviously Japanese literature
published on it there's it's harder to
find in our literature because it's just
not that common but we have we now have
dendritic cells as well so we have those
in Mexico so we're offering dendritic
cells and natural killer cells for
people just as as a complimentary
potential treatment I'm not saying don't
do chemo I'm just saying why not try to
do at least at the very least do both
because it can only help chemo as well
and there's going to studies on that too
okay so for the average person cuz I'm
sure there's going to be somebody
listening who isn't like loaded and
can't afford to do some of these
treatments is this like say they were in
Japan is this something that's just
standard or is it also super expens
expensive I would say like I would say
if you don't have the means to do these
Excel therapies and they are very
expensive still because it's a
relatively new technology then doing a
minimally you know invasive approach
where you're trying to get your own
immune system to fight the cancer so
what does that mean so do that doc back
to Dr Tom what he does he uses exercise
with oxygen and he uses micronutrients
and he looks at all these different
toxins in your body that can be the
reason why your body can't heal and
fight the cancer so he's just using
exercise with oxygen therapy and
nutritional and mineral protocols and
he's he's having a high success rate he
told me he's only had one patient in the
last 6 months who hasn't survived and he
gets stage four cases and all sorts of
cases so that's crazy I know when Mom
had cancer and we were looking at
everything and she was already on like
she was on a ketogenic
diet we were looking into micronutrient
therapy which I didn't understand in the
least was like I don't understand how
that works but anyway putting that aside
do people assume that the reason people
get cancer now because you do see
somewhat healthy people and suddenly
that they have cancer is that from
biotoxin overload yeah toxin overload
that's the leading theory and Mark
linten who you will bring on your show
can go more detailed into it but his
theory for people who are curious is
called cell suppression Theory and he
has a book published now and essentially
what happens is these intracellular
pathogens which are mainly fungal spores
that we're all exposed to oh my gosh see
I keep spouting off off about mold and
people are like oh is it mold the cause
behind is that cause behind everything I
was like maybe I'm not sure uh she's is
not wrong it's actually a contributing
factor most likely in almost all chronic
diseases it's one of those like low
hanging fruits like similar to gut
disbiosis like we all it's so common
nowadays where we have imbalanced gut
bacteria I would say fungal spores falls
into that category as well where we're
we all probably have them in ourselves
but some of us because for genetic
reasons can't clear it or because our
immune system becomes weaken over time
then it starts causing issues down the
road so the best way to deal with it on
a very high level is just High High
sweat like just do high intensity
exercise where you're sweating because
you have to you have to physically sweat
and sauna sweat it doesn't do it is it
it activates these lipases which help to
mobilize toxins from your fat and they
only get mobilized when you're sweating
in from physical exercise why why why
wouldn't a sauna work because the it's
called hormone sensitive lipase hsl it's
a lipas enzyme that gets activated that
helps to remove these toxins from your
fat but it only gets activated with
physical exercise and movement not just
from sweating oh my gosh I haven't
exercised to the point of sweating in
like I have no idea exactly I don't
remember the last and some people can't
sweat and have you ever wondered why
they can't sweat well yeah why does that
Happ because it's like a protective the
fungal spores are protect yeah basically
like they don't want to get out so it's
like it makes it harder for your body to
sweat it's like they they're smart
they're oh my gosh okay okay can you
explain this then so I'm really used to
saing and I've Saed for a long time
because like
previously it's made me feel better and
I have a sauna here and I've been saing
because I was exposed to mold and I was
like I want a detox I'm not sweating
properly and I've talked to Jordan about
this because I've been like I used to be
this Pro sauna goer and just like 20
minutes in there and I'm drenched and
it's been like 40 minutes and I have
like little tiny droplets and things
could that be from being exposed to mold
that is [__] yeah they're smart
they're smart little oh my gosh that
explains it okay yeah so we got to get
you a sweat we'll get you a sweat suit
cuz sweat it is what it is you wear it
when you out and it helps you sweat and
you can order it online oh my gosh okay
I'm glad we did just the podcast just
for that because this sauna thing's been
weirding me like really weirding me out
it's like I I don't feel like they're
working as well and I heard people talk
online like oh I can't sauna it doesn't
make me feel good and I was like well
maybe you should just suck it up and
stay in there longer like I don't know
what's going on and now I'm like one of
those people I didn't know what was
going on I was like I'm not sweating for
some reason no exactly like the reality
is there's something so again I'm Gonna
Keep name dropping Dr Tom because he's a
world expert on this from what I've seen
and he he tests he he says there's
86,000 toxins now in the environment
86,000 that's nice so how how how how
can you even like what what are we going
to do right the environment's the
environment we can't change modern
society it is it's already too too far
gone so all we can do is build
resiliency and try to do do build the
right do the right tools so that we can
deal with these toxins h a sweatsuit
sweatsuit I hadn't heard of that yeah
that seems very useful and it's not like
SAA or infrared technology or is it kind
of infrared help no no it it it I I
think it just helps your body to sweat
more I don't know the exact mechanism
okay but yeah I'm going to look into
that that's cool wow okay okay and then
you talked a little bit about how
expensive and like I had tons of
comments about like these are so
expensive like how do normal people
afford this but can you talk a little
bit about the price of stem cells and
yeah I mean the price is actually
cheaper than when it came on last year
so that's progress so that's progress
right like I think last year we said it
was like 25,000 for an IV and now it's
like 15 to 20 so yeah and why is it
going down because the manufacturing is
improving so we're able to use something
called uh bioreactors where you can grow
more stem cells at a cheaper cost and
it's going to and and that's just going
to get better now let's I think in
another year or two once we have the
second gener generation ones and those
are at scale then those one will be the
expensive ones for like you know let's
say celebrities pro athletes people who
have more money and then the first
generation will be even more affordable
so I think it's it's only going to keep
getting better I and I think the best
analogy now that I think about is like
those do do you remember those plasma
TVs but when they first came out they
were like some of them were like $50,000
or $100,000 like now you can get them
for like 500 bucks yeah so it's like you
know this happens this is the
technological innov but there has to be
early adopters who are willing to say
okay not I mean yes there there's a
selfless component of saying okay I'm
willing to do this because I can afford
it and it's going to pave the way for
future for more people to do it in the
future and I think that's the mindset of
a lot of people I have I know you know
obviously a lot of celebrities and
people I treat their that's kind of
their mindset too is that they know this
exactly because they know this is going
to help Humanity down the road similar
to how electric vehicles like Elon mus
when he had to get Tesla in 2010 he had
to he gave it to like near Leonardo
DiCaprio like Tom Cruz like he was just
he just like take a free car because he
wants him to just drive it and promote
it and but once but the car back then
was pretty crappy like it didn't go very
far it was just a bunch of batteries
taped together like it was so but the
technology improved and it paved the way
for better technology and I think that's
the same thing with sell and gene
therapy so gene therapy already like
yeah again it's it is expensive right
now but I believe in like 5 years the
fallest DAT in will be probably like a
fifth the price oh wow yeah that's
really cool um where have you been cuz
you've been around talking to doctors
and seeing what like the most Cutting
Edge therapies are where in the world
have you been do you think that's
Advanced the
furthest I mean in my space definitely
Asia like I think uh
China
Japan and even South I haven't been to
South Korea yet but I'm planning to go
this summer are probably are probably
the leaders when it comes to tissue
engineering cell therapy and therapy and
like really moving this field forward
more from a clinical translation side as
opposed to just research like I think us
still has some of the in Canada too has
some of the best and brightest
scientists but the problem is our
Regulators don't allow for a lot of the
stuff that we're actually making this
amazing breakthrough science on because
they're so strict and stringent about
what can be done when I don't think it's
I think I think the J Japanese model Mak
so much more sense to me which is saying
that okay we have a regulatory framework
and we know that these things are safe
they're very unlikely to cause harm and
they have a lot of potential benefit so
why don't we allow them for people who
want them that I mean it's very logical
to me and that's why stem cells have
culture expanded stem cells which are
the ones are manufactured and grown for
like three or four weeks which are
illegal in the USA have been around in
Japan for 10 years so I think it just it
just makes you question why are the
Japanese doing this to like a such a
large scale to their own population yeah
exactly exactly and whereas here it's
like well do we really want people to
get better or you know who's who's
controlling the regulatory bodies right
yeah is this just so is it just the
pharmaceutical companies I mean there I
think um Dr John Abraham he was on Lex
freedman's podcast and he has a great he
has if you guys if people who really
want to dig into this it's an hour and a
half long but and he has a book called
sickening but the gist of it is I'll
give you the high level summary pharmac
companies have some there's something
called a revolving door which is like
big Pharma go they the people who are
CEOs and Executives there often go into
FDA go into scdc and they kind of just
like revolve around those different
places so in basically in reg like
insiders from the industry are going
into the regulatory body so what's so
who's who are they going to help out
they're going to help out their buddies
that they know right so it's just that's
just unfortunately the way it is that's
that's the biggest problem but there's
many many other problems in terms of
like how these things get approved how
they're how pharmaceutical companies are
good at getting approvals because they
know how to work the system because some
of the drugs don't even do much like
like there's so many examples but even
like there's one called trulicity which
is like this um diabetic drug and
there's something called number needed
to treat which is like how many people
actually need to take this to have a
real meaningful benefit on their health
and the number need to treat was
something like
327 that means 327 people so if you give
it to a th people like three benefit
three people actually benefit from it
and this is FDA approved and because
they were just able to do like you know
just have a large enough sample size to
make it statistically significant and
like just they know how to work the
system basically and John Abraham he he
he really talks a lot about that
abrahamson or yeah his book is called
sickening though but it's a really good
eye openening
topic sounds yeah that sounds like
somebody good to get on too that's awful
that's awful I feel like when you grow
up especially when you grow up in Canada
at least when I grew up I was like I was
told that we had the best healthare
system in the world over and over and
over again best in the entire world and
then when it really came down to it when
I needed surgery like now was like oh
this is terrible and they're like yeah
you might want to go to India we were
literally considering we had a Visa
booked to get me an ankle replacement in
India because there was a three-year
waiting list in Canada and I was like
suicidal with pain India that's and I
was like okay well I I thought the same
thing funny you said that cuz that's
what I was like oh I'm so lucky I get to
go to a Canadian med school I'm going to
the best I'm getting the best medical
education in the world and and honestly
a lot of my colleagues still think that
and that's probably part of the reason
why they're not they're not really
understanding where what's happening in
medicine because they think they've
already learned everything there's to
learn and what they need to learn is
being distilled from a very specific
lens of guidelines and those guidelines
are coming from Specialists and those
Specialists have ties more often than
not to pharmaceutical companies because
they're the top tier specialist and they
always get poached and recruited by
these pharmaceutical companies and so
the guidelines are essentially just a
reflection of a bunch of Specialists who
are might be the top in their field but
unfortunately they have their own biases
and
so so if you if if you actually look at
it and you start going outside the
guidelines then you're you're considered
not doing things that are standard of
care and then that's where it becomes
hard for live doctors to be like and so
obviously what I'm doing is not standard
of care Canada but in other countries it
is and in other countries people are
benefiting Plus for me it's always a
discussion now with my patients it's I I
offered them I'm like okay well you can
get a hip replacement or you can try
this stem cell procedure these are the
success rates this is the pros and
benefits and you can decide most of them
rather do the less invasive procedure
that can potentially have the same
outcome why why not and why why
shouldn't they have that option and the
fact that they have to travel outside
the country to do that is kind of
baffling to me but that's the current
state so let's talk about joint
replacements for a second how far like
what how far gone is a patient that
you've seen that's recovered like for me
from just to give you an example like
when I got my hip replaced it was there
was no cartilage and it was bone on bone
and the bone was starting to break down
so it was at that point yeah can you
resolve something that far gone or have
you seen that or is it like before that
yeah that is we have had cases with that
and now especially because we just got
hydrogels so hydrogels yeah I think I
talked about them last year and now we
have them finally uh so we have the
first generation of hydrogels which is
essentially a scaffold in which the stem
cells are embedded into but this
hydrogel spe specifically is really cool
is from a company in Portugal and what
it does is you can inject it using just
a regular syringe so you don't have to
do surgery but then it cross links once
it goes inside so it forms this like
scaffold mesh how do you how do you know
where to put it just by the inject c
yeah we use ultrasound guidance to go
right into the joint or into wherever
the wherever we need to scaffold and so
what that allows is allows the stem
cells to embed better which allows for
more engraftment and regeneration and it
it really depends on what is causing the
pain because if if it's purely
mechanical because there's like no joint
space and it's like hitting bone on bone
then obviously stem cells aren't going
to help that but if it's more so I was
[__] anyway probably probably okay
well that's good because it's repl
that's kind want to hear although now
what we're what we're working on is the
tissue engineering with 3D bioprinters
yeah that's exciting so we have an
orthopedic surgeon on our team and we're
talking with a company called tissue
labs in Switzerland and basically what
we want to do with them is we want to
explore if we can actually 3D bioprint
an entire resurfacing essentially of the
joint so then in your case where you had
no cartilage you would resurface it
using this uh SC this 3D bioprint to
scaffold arthroscopically and then it
would with stem cells it would re
generate new tissue oh my gosh that
would be so good so that's not far away
that's like that's already been done in
animals and there's a group in
University of Washington doing that too
and so I I don't think that's that's
less than definitely less than five
years but I'm hoping by next year we'll
be offering it in clinical trials wow oh
that's really exciting when I um I had
my ankle replaced and they put the
replacement in crooked slightly crooked
uh for and I didn't know that for about
10 years I was in chronic pain and I was
going to surgeons to try and find
somebody to reace my ankle cuz I was
like at this point I don't even want a
foot anymore like was like it hurt so
much I was like I would probably be
better off if it was just not there and
I went to the surgeon who was taking
kadaver joints so he'd find eventually
he'd find someone who's like a suitable
size to you and I went to talk to him
and I was like can you do that to me and
like give me back my ankle and he just
he didn't even it was so sad he didn't
even charge me for the appointment he
was like no it just doesn't work like
they'd been trying to do it and they
just weren't working and he was like you
know just fly home I'm sorry yeah well
that I mean this is what's called
synthetic biology which is where we can
manufacture cells and tissue to the to
the degree that we want that's the
that's the era we're heading we're in
the beginning of synthetic biology but
in 20 years from now we're going to look
back and be like wow that was really
barbaric what we were doing back then
yeah so it's uh it's but it's it's just
a beginning of that Revolution but it's
exciting because obviously there's so
much promise in this field and this is
just a it's literally there's a whole
community of scientists who are
brilliant and doing so much amazing work
that I know for a like I can I'm very
confident that this stuff like joint
replacement surgery will be a thing of
the past within our lifetimes like for
sure that's cool okay if that happens
I'm going to get you guys to re repace
my joints with real real you just create
bio artificial yeah or like basically
ankle yeah regrow you a different ankle
yeah oh that's so cool okay let's see
what else do I have on here oh this is
this is this should be an easier
question is what to do to to lessen
scars so so yeah first understand if
it's if it's K like a choid or
hypertrophic SCAR or even from Burns
we've had great results using the
culture expanded stem cells and this is
where dosing becomes important because
if you're just using non-expanded ones
like the ones that are available in the
US the dose is maybe 500,000 to like a
million stem cells which just isn't High
Enough
to change the tissue architecture
meaning you have to remodel to to treat
scarring basically you're remodeling the
tissue and that remodeling there has to
be signals that are strong enough that
send those signals and that's where we
use like culture expanded stem cells
like again like a 30 million dose or
something and we would put it into the
scar directly and it can actually
remodel it and it can it can flatten it
out and make it much much lighter it
doesn't just turn into Scar Tissue no
no now have a super no yeah exactly no
stem cells are actually exactly and
that's the cool thing about stem stem
cells are kind of more like chameleons
they kind of wherever you inject them
they help they kind of camouflage or
turn into like the local tissue around
them so that's that's their cool that's
their job and one of their one of their
uh main effects uh is antifibrosis or
antifibrotic meaning it helps with
fibrosis or scarring that's why it's
it's we can use it even with caronic
fibrosis or scarring for different
organs and but obviously scarring is no
different and so now now that we have
the second generation exome
we're using that and stem cells together
for scarring okay do you think that
works better than like lasers like CO2
yeah no because I've had many patients
who tried that we're we're usually the
last resort because our stuff is yeah
obviously more yeah expensive um so most
of my P like we've treat many scars and
a lot of them are people who've already
tried all that stuff yeah okay so
they're usually tried all the
traditional things and they're kind of
like well what else is it what else is
out there and that's how they end up
with us okay what what's your favorite
treatment that you do honestly I think
it's be becoming the Vegas Nerf because
of how satisfying it is to see how much
it changes people's lives and how
quickly I guess I like the immediate
gratification whereas with stem cells
like often it can take months to see the
results and you know your soul is kind
of like washing paint dry you're like
you want to see how people are doing but
just it it often takes time chronic pain
might be quicker but for other
conditions it does take like four to six
months so with with vas nerve like like
I was saying that like girl like I've
had like those special forces army guys
like they Lally like within 10 minutes
they're like crying because their life
just changed and they're going back from
being suicidal to not being suicidal and
living a normal life like with the
10-minute procedure like I just I just
find that so like it's just it's amazing
to watch and it's it's it's it's kind of
sad in a sense that like it's not
accessible like it's like very few
people know about it and that that this
is even an option for them U because
there's so many people with mental
health conditions that are rooted in
unresolved emotional trauma and that
unresolved emotional trauma stays in
your nervous system and that's why the
Vegas nerve injection is so powerful
because it's resetting and rebooting
your nervous system and if if if you can
do the work the deep root cause work of
working with someone going to your
childhood and really exploring that
whether that's with psychedelics or
without I think that's where a lot of
the best benefits are for therapy but
we're doing it just in an Interventional
form yeah that's so interesting so for
people who can't do the Interventional
form that's where psychedelics or just I
guess that's where like writing out your
past and just trying to work through
Russell Kennedy who you should bring on
your show too he he wrote a book called
anxiety RX and it's probably the best
book I've seen on anxiety but it's all
about how to work like you said writing
it down but working through and having a
step-wise approach to how to get to the
root of unresolved emotional trauma or
childhood trauma that you didn't even
think was trauma but is actually what is
causing you from having this anxiety or
having this depression and that's what
Russell candy talks about and he's his
success rates are way higher than like
CBT and like you know cognitive
behavioral therapy and standard of care
therapy because CBT results are not that
great and people and it it takes like 12
24 weeks and a lot of times people don't
get benefit from it so so I I think
we're really starting to understand uh
and probably Gober mate and you know a
lot of people who did the initial work
on adverse childhood events and that
type of stuff really set the foundation
for us to understand that hey these
these adverse sh events are actually
probably one of the main drivers for
chronic neuros psychiatric disorders and
those adverse childhood events too they
don't have to look like trauma right to
everybody around them it can just be
something that like Dr Kennedy Russell
was telling me that like he's had cases
where because he does he helps a lot of
people with these uh different um
disorders where people had chronic
anxiety and it was related to them
getting left at home when their parents
took other child to a vacation and then
like just something simple as that just
like but the child remembers being alone
with their grandparents and and being
forgotten about and you know like things
like that which you would never think
would be a trauma but maybe it is for
nervous you know what I mean so go so
anxiety-provoking as a
parent like what am I what do I do I
know
that's exactly as a as a parent too now
it's like and that was the same that was
funny same reaction I had so I'm like
I'm like rest how do I prevent my kids
from like not having any trauma when
they're older so you got to be so
cognizant of the small it's it could be
the smallest things right and I think
that's where communication and really
having that emotional intelligence and
resiliency and building that in your
kids is that cuz you can't you can't
also keep them safe and not expose them
to anything or they're going to go out
in the real world and instantly be
traumatized yeah exactly oh man how old
is your kid now are you enjoying being a
dad well I have a five-month old boy but
I have also two girls so who are three
well four and three now so so yeah it's
fun I mean I think the favorite my
favorite part about is watching them
change and develop but I think I think
one of the things I've I've I've read a
few books because I think the
interesting thing is in society it's
like why don't we ever get educated on
how to become a good parent how how to
become educated so that we can actually
do a good job because if you if you do a
good job with parenting that's going to
make such a big difference for Society
for like everything right like uh and I
found the two biggest things I've read
about which i' be curious to hear your
thoughts are instilling self-efficacy
and creativity in children because those
are two of the most important skill sets
that Foster like a s you know a
successful resilient child like that
they believe in themselves if they work
hard at something they can succeed and
then obviously creativity is pretty
self-explanatory and school tends to
kill creativity in the mod modern form
it is and I I had this experience with
Scarlet so I've got a six-year-old and
I've always been like she's going to
love like reading cuz I used to love
reading although I'm thinking now that
maybe part of the reason I liked it so
much is cuz I wasn't running around as
much as a normal kid cuz of the
arthritis and was like immersing myself
in books sounds good I don't know I
might have liked books anyway but but
she's like she's interested in drawing
and I was and I was like that's cool but
I always I was like you should be
interested in reading and I just gave up
recently because I L looked at one of
the paintings she did compared to other
kids her age and I was like oh she's
actually really good at painting like
maybe I should be like you draw draw
your heart out who cares about reading
you can learn that thoroughly it's not
like you're going to be illiterate when
you grow up um and school does kind of
kill that oh yeah I mean I think if you
don't fit into their box which is I mean
I think school was designed I mean this
is I'm pretty sure it was for factory
workers basically which is like meaning
that it's it's replicable it's it's
meant for just getting people out into
Workforce and doing regular jobs but
regular jobs in the next 10 years
especially by because machine learning
and AI are going to be most of them are
going to be replaced so so a lot of it
becomes knowledge work and creativity
work and that's something that education
system is really not Preparing People
for so that's why I'm a huge believer in
travel and like I I mean I travel all
over but taking my kids with me I think
is so good for their brain and so good
for their development because then they
see different perspectives and it just
you see things differently yeah so do
they go over to Dubai over there when
they work over there yeah and I'm going
to take them to Japan this summer so oh
wow yeah I'm gonna be working in Japan
for two months or so and I'm excited
because not only learning more about
stem cells but the gene therapy stuff
too because they've uh I mean it's it's
it's the birthplace of the yamanaka stem
cells which is the gene edited stem
cells so there's there's obviously a lot
of amazing scientists over there and do
you just have connections with people
who are like willing to show you around
like teach you what they're doing or how
do you get in there and yeah I'm good at
networking that's uh a lot of it is yeah
a lot of it it's a Comm it's like a
community right of regenerative medicine
people like I would say And scientists
and people who are actually trying to do
good work meaning just trying to like
improve the science like using and like
it's it's kind of cheesy but at the end
day most of the scientists we all just
want to help people and like we every
scientist's dream is for their work to
make an impact on people's lives like
and and so a lot of them that's and they
see a lot of them like I found a lot of
them like me because they see that I'm
really trying to go out there and trying
to put this into people and trying to
really move the field forward as much as
I can and unfortunately I have to go
outside of US and Canada but that's
that's the nature of it for now and I
think I I'm hoping
the more I learn in Japan and the more I
can kind of hopefully show the
government maybe back home that hey you
know this is a very successful model
over here and it actually saves US money
because you prevent disease or it's less
costly than surgery there's all these
actual economic benefits too which get
overlooked all the time mhm you think if
someone just had a conversation with the
right person in the government you'd be
like hey look Japan's doing it they're
ahead don't you also want to be ahead ex
like what are we doing yeah exactly even
just like forget about helping people
like there's a comp comption here you're
losing just that aspect yeah it depends
on which bureaucrat you're talking to
yeah yeah
definitely okay
well I think that's good thank you very
much for coming on that was really
interesting and I think maybe I'll have
you on again and then we can talk about
what happens with the fall of Staten and
whatever else you learn cuz you've
learned a ton I mean this was a new
conversation from last year yeah so we
should do this again yeah no for sure
and hopefully you can come down to Cabo
and we can do some of the other other
stuff too for you oh my gosh definitely
I definitely want to do the Vegas thing
that sounds great rather than work
through all my trauma like that sounds
that's going to take so many shrooms no
it just makes it well this makes it so
much easier yeah all right till then
okay thank you all
[Music]
right